how's it going everybody it's Warren and
Avengers in game was amazing everybody's
still talking about what we saw with the
movie there are so many amazing scenes
in the movie it's hard to pick which one
your favorite is they're all so good but
as it turns out there were a few epic
scenes that didn't make their way into
the movie and one of those scenes
involved Thor and Iron Man in the
original script for the movie when the
Avengers go back in time originally it
was supposed to be Tony Stark going back
to Asgard with Thor not only did I earn
man go with Thor in the original draft
but he also fought Heimdall which is
interesting to hear that the original
script had Heimdall in it because we did
not see him in avengers endgame but one
of the writers for Avengers infinity war
and Avengers endgame told us all about
this scene in an interview with Fandango
Stephen McFeely in the interview said
yeah our first draft was a version where
Tony and Thor go to ask guard because I
like the idea of Tony going like in
theory going to Asgard and seen science
versus magic and stuff like that and
then he fought Heimdall who could of
course see him even though Tony had an
invisible stealth suit on or something
writer stephen mcfeely went on to talk
about why they originally had
Iron Man going to Asgard with Thor he
said and we did that because there is in
dark world to get technical about it
during that time when the reality stone
is there the space stone is also in the
vault so at the end of dark world you
might remember that Volstagg and SIF go
to the collector and pass off the
reality stone because they don't want to
keep the two stones in one place so that
was one attempt at it and I think Jill
Rousseau read it and he goes why aren't
we going to Avengers it's only the most
exciting movie and so we went yep let's
do that the other writer for infinity
war and in game Christopher Marcus added
we were initially hesitant to go back to
the first Avengers movie because it
seemed like we were just pandering and
playing to the greatest hits
you like that movie we're going right
back to that movie and then it really
became clear we were overthinking it in
terms of what would be the most fun and
I have to agree I think that Tony and
Captain America going back to the Battle
of New York was a really fun thing to
watch but I do think that it would have
been super awesome to see a fight
between Heimdall and Iron Man and it's
interesting because it seems like they
were going to give Iron Man's suit some
sort of invisible
cloak which why not it's nanotechnology
can do basically everything so why not
give it invisibility it would have been
really cool to see Iron Man try to sneak
around all stealth like but then run
into Heimdall because of course Heimdall
could see him then get an awesome fight
between the two of them of course until
Thor would show up but again I do like
how they did it with Tony and Captain
going back to the very first Avengers
film at the Battle of New York but let
me know what you all think about this
would you have liked to seen a battle
between Heimdall and Iron Man or are you
satisfied with the scene that we've got
Tony and Captain America going back to
the original Avengers film let me know
what scene you prefer in the comments
down below and let me know that if
Heimdall and Tony did fight who you
think would win comment Iron Man or Tony
down below and be sure to LIKE the video
and subscribe if you're new to my
channel so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to Marvel and all
things superhero as always thank you all
so much for watching well fool
congratulations to your desperation to
save the universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it very nice and
dull it took you said it cost you
everything while crying like a baby
now you're no